continuez à truites et continue à nous
mettre des messages sur facebook
vraiment vous êtes vraiment des amours
les cherry et jean-luc alors qu'est ce
qui va se passer on va rappeler le
principe de votre séquence aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils nous rejoignent
ce soir alors le principe c'est simple
c'est que je me suis servi de tout ce
qui se passait pendant les publicités
pour les magnétos qu'on diffusait pour
découvrir nos amis sous un autre jour
sabawi révélé ça nos téléspectateurs
merci alors et là j'en ai je vais faire
des ennemis sarraut cède alors je vais
je vais je vais lâcher des dossiers
enfin je suis pas sûr ah oui on va voir
on va voir comment ça se passe si les
gens sont gentils je dis rien s'ils sont
méchants je lâche tu es beau tu es
magnifique et tu as trahi la morale il
n'aime pas les pots crise il va lâcher
mieux reconnaît alésien vous trouvez que
c'est hypocrite quand il fait beau
bonjour je m'appelle françoise je
voudrais savoir quels sont les pires
fera jamais prononcée dans l'émission à
part j'aime la tob évidemment c'est une
excellente question que vous posez là
chers proposés et surtout une magnifique
marque de confiance
car si vous étiez tombé sur un esprit
malveillant il aurait pu se diffuser à
l'antenne
j'aime la table évidemment et rassurez
vous ça je ne le ferai pas sérieusement
je voulais adresser un grand merci aux
gens que nous avons sollicités toute
l'année pour leur humour stoop leur
gentillesse et à déborah tous les cadres
qui ont rencontré toute l'année donc
merci merci les chéris merci alors pour
répondre à la question évidemment eu des
phrases hallucinant de prononcer cette
année et je m'étais dit que pour finir
j'avais tout déstocker ah oui au pas et
puis j'ai eu des remords dans si j'ai eu
des remords oh non il ya des choses qui
doivent rester cachés j'ai eu des
remords jusqu'à mardi à la première
coupure pub horizon fermé le truc par
jean diot jeanneau diot
jean-luc ya plus de 4 hier je peux
bosser la radio
ah non c'est fini et qui tient prête à
vous plaît j'essayais ce qu'on pense
vraiment
à las vegas était pas fini
écoutez on va faire un deal 1 on écoute
ce que vous avez dit sur moi si c'est
sympa je ne révèle rien c'est pas ça
passe je lâche tout et on punit tout le
monde à cause de vous deux mais s'ajuste
je trouve ça on va écouter ce qu'il
raconte la jeune relève en les doublant
dallaire c'est pas drôle
photo andré dossat traite
toi tu as dit que tu puisses c'est
gratuit tout ça c'était le petit caillou
en fait le petit cadeau
tu es le grand mère je trouve pas ça
sympa je suis d'accord il faut donc je
crois qu'on va déstocker aujourd'hui
alors il parfois que il arrive parfois
que jean-michel ne puisse pas bien
préparé l'émission s'est souvent plaint
eh ben on croit que c'était juste dû à
ses sorties et bat pas que c'est surtout
un problème matériel
il a cassé son ordinateur c'est donc
acheté une tablette et les tablettes
c'est pas simple pour regarder les
replays enfin ça c'est lui qui nous
l'expliquent ripper votre mari il faut
une application spéciale tellement
sidérant replay sur ipad et les
provinces ça marche pas je sème ska de
plus j'aurai des vidéos messages double
ça c'est rien c'est du petit déstockage
ya quinze jours je vous avais montré ce
que penser de thierry moreau de l'humour
de cyril hanouna
oui rappelez vous
j'ai appelé dans ton style mais un
niveau qui au nom fait du gaultier parce
que c'est ton patron d'écurie pas non
plus de records il a persisté à dire que
j'ai failli ne pas le faire sauter tout
à l'heure c'est dommage j'aurais
peut-être mieux fait d'enlever le truc
est superflu alors quand je montre ce
genre de off les gens disent que je suis
méchant
et ben non je suis sorti parce que
j'avais pas montré la suit dans enfin
j'avais pas montré la suite parce qu'à
l'époque je ne savais pas que j'avais un
physique improbable à jean-michel plus
d'humour qu il a persisté
il a les meilleurs à noter les gens de
renfort et pourraient en faire une table
je rejoins des prochaines bienvenue
julien voulzy l'appui sera avec nous à
la rentrée sur d'éviter dans touche pas
bon mais c'est comme ça je dis à mon
sujet propre nom mais rassure toi je
viens il dit du mal de tout mon nom mais
pas de vous vous êtes fous toi ici
maintenant
jean-michel il dit que des choses bonnes
sur vous mais si vous savez pour
jean-michel avec le patron tout et
extase c'est vrai qu'il est sympa
il arrive à danser
au genou
jared est en toi tu là ta première place
au palmarès mais t'as intérêt à faire
attention parce que tu as un nouveau
challenger 1
et pas n'importe qui
google
tellement déçu j'attendais mieux de
gilles il se révolte contre tous mais
dans le genre fayot mais c'est un beau
minable coûte il a envie que ce soit
beau chez un ami non mais c'est vraiment
le roi des fées ont regardé cyril va
dire un truc
ouais un truc brillant je vous laisse la
surprise
eh ben il y en a qu'un qui va applaudir
la déclaration du chef d' easy ça mérite
pas ça je n'aurais pas montrer ainsi si
les deux n'avaient pas payé mardi comme
enora à j'aurais jamais montré comment
elle se prépare avant l'émission pour
être au top à vous pouvez quand même pas
que ça vient comme ça
je me mets dans la peau de la vénèrent
la méchante à partir de ma vente et
méchant à partir de maintenant je vous
[ __ ] tous je pense que tout ça c'est à
cause de jean michel est pour l'heure en
hommage à tous les deux j'ai voulu
m'intéresser à l amitié ambigüe qui les
lie et surtout à son évolution tout au
long de l'année
c'est beau enchaîner les mots et beau
gosse marié bové le bateau
manquer maman
il tord pas trop tiède
non
oui
mais quand je vois ma seule consolation
ne
un chien ne fait pas ça
l'écran
je m'approche de toi je
qui n'a jamais rapporté une bouteille
parce que je suis adhérent depuis dix
ans tu m'as jamais rapporté s'être cassé
les mois j'ai rapporté salle de valérie
tient pis toi tu vas être fermoir tiens
ma balle ou et au suivant les quartiers
ste claire
mais sa toile gt gt grande jusque là je
vais pas faire vous c'est moi j'étais
parti sadi
j'étais dans le film quoi ils vont jouer
bach de lalala j'étais dans le lagon
bleu royal l'eau dans le gaz de lévis
entre les deux donc isabelle morini-bosc
baisse et dit qu'ils avaient peut-être
une brèche dévoué tête
enfin raconter sa vie à thierry devenir
son ami un grand moment de solitude et
vous allez voir quand il s'appelle ne
sait plus quoi dire ben et tape dans les
mains
s'agirait de retrouver ma première et ma
terminale mais j'ai eu le bac à 20 ans
musulmane
comme quoi
un mec qui saoule le public sa vie
totalement
c'est vrai mais vous la pauvre ma chérie
mais vous savez quand on sait plus quoi
dire
dans les bassins est toujours en fait
c'est quand elle est au bout du rouleau
et oui mais s'appuie sur lui non mais
regardez le rien parce que je me suis
rendu compte de ce petit hic quand elle
est vraiment pour se donner une
contenance est stable dans les mains
j'avais remarqué ça lors de la venue de
gary dourdan sur notre plateau et vous
allez voir il va y avoir un échange de
regards entre isabelle le beau gars y et
puis plus rien donc qu'est ce qu'il va
faire
mais c'est une occasion rare une autre
question à l'élocution bonjour cyrine je
m'appelle john bertrand je suis designer
capillaire est-ce que l'année prochaine
vous comptez vous agir ou est-ce que les
gens qui travaillent avec vous seront
encore obligé de porter des perruques
ridicule merci c'est franck à pied tall
directeur des divertissements et des
magazines
2/2 je le remercie d'avoir joué le jeu
et comme je sais qu'il ne le fera plus
jamais j'ai une autre prise si vous
voulez nancy avec un retournement a dit
allez on y va bonjour cyril je m'appelle
john bertrand je suis designer
capillaires à ce que l'année prochaine
vous comptez vous agir ou est-ce que les
gens qui travaillaient avec vous seront
encore obligé de porter des perruques
ridicule je devais dire m mais jean luc
lemoine je te déteste avec m parce que m
c'est moche pour bien régler ce midi
ciel nom cyrill ne va pas s'assagir et
non il ne martyrise pas ses chroniqueurs
juste une façon particulière de s'en
occuper que comme ici les reproches à me
roy
ouvrez des petits 14 mois c'est comme
mon petit frère mais le feu s'était
montrée sans éclat tiers je me suis dit
que j'allais vous calmer mais pas du
tout même si rien ne bat d'or ça c'est
lui qui m'attaquent tout le temps même
attaque a promis à plélo il attaque
toujours là et et mokhtar qui attaque
qui ne m'attaque vraiment vendu tous et
mokhtar le nom mais il n'a pas tort ce
que s'il est une mère pour nous avec un
qui s'intéressent à la vie des autres
alors je vais trahir un secret pendant
les pubs il se mure centre là juste là
entre les tables et il fait son petit
tour en trouvant toujours la bonne
question en fonction du chroniqueur
total avait ton cul aussi
marca faut pas rigoler ça ça vraiment
merrifield dans le mac était vraiment
acquis excusez-nous non vraiment c'est
mais c'est parce que j'aime bien les
câliner enfin je sais pas si vous avez
bien entendu mais vous noterez au
passage que valérie bénaïm est prête
pour intégrer les anges de la télé
réalité ça marche pas rigoler gaza et
oui on récolte à sa lan cyril est
fascinant tout au long de cette année
j'ai essayé de vous réveiller et révéler
certains de ses secrets
lui qui réussit à faire des choses que
le commun des mortels est incapable de
faire une nouvelle preuve avec cette
révélation étonnante d'enora malagré
toutes les pizzas qui enchaînent les
passes et ou conjoint
je suis de rouen courtois
j'y mets mon rappelant que ma maison
oui
destockage 0 et oui je suis désolé
frérot je pourrais plus jamais pécho une
map de ma vie quand les civils et les
gants mais non mais c'est pas tes nature
fait ça franchement tu te considérais
que tu as une belle complicité qu'on
attendait plutôt d'accord nous a fait
non je veux pas savoir garde le mystère
évidemment si je vous ai fait cette
révélation ce uniquement pour vous dire
que ces îles à la 4g dans ses toilettes
à l'époque quelque chose de plus grave
vous savez nous avons fait toute sorte
de happening cette année mais ce que
vous ne savez pas c'est qu'à un peu
nigaud odieux est resté au stade de
projet et si tout ça c'est vraiment le
dossier indiffusables ont là non on va
passer à la suite enfin on va faire on
va au bout la rubrique je vous laisse
réfléchir pour savoir si vous voulez
vraiment voir ce dossier car je vous
préviens un happening qu'on n'a jamais
fait c'est le plus honteux et rien ne
sera plus jamais comme avant après je
vous laisse réfléchir mais on a trop
envie c'est ça oui moi je vois je suis
par ailleurs savoir le diffuser voilà en
tout cas dernier tiers de l'année
je ne pouvais pas finir sans rendre
hommage à la danse et à celle qui nous a
enchantés avec ses créations
isabelle morini-bosc donc pour la
dernière fois la copie de notre danseuse
étoile
c
oh
non
7e
les biens son histoire
je
alors
et quelques labels alors le dossier
je vais vous dire vous me connaissez je
suis joueur oh la la
cette fois ci j'ai décidé de ne pas
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
ok on veut voir le dossier
voilà bon je vous préviens je vous avais
dit moi je ne voulais pas le montrer
mais cc c'est quand même quelque chose
qui était à la limite de l'attentât ça
faisait suite à la révélation d'enora
sur les activités de signer l'auto let
non vous êtes sûr allez vous l'aurais
voulu
il a tort l'image des heures et demie
avec son portable et twitter google
pour ces problèmes de quoi ses comptes
et ses comptes est ce que tu chies sur
la caisse de devoir voir jean-michel
éclatant
si vous appelez marc bureau non mais
c'est quoi cette semaine le midi
tu te rends arrive ça le dauphin à deux
heures après tu nous appelles pour enfin
chacun
son but
inaba
c'est non alors si je peux mourir pour
qui le foot et le succès des cours
j'ai compris dit [ __ ] il ya un pigeon
et non halal à la vérité viendra vous
dire la vérité
c'était vraiment un projet qu'on invente
est jeune on avait 13 ans j'adore le mot
projets labellisés boxe avait élaboré un
week end j'avais appelé jean luc g super
idée je vais chier sur la caisse de
louvain j'ai trouvé le truc qu'on va
faire et voilà nous avons malade le
museler pas fait sony n'a pas fait de
mal a pas fait il est pas vrai et en
quinze jours que les héros quand je le
regrette
là c'était les dernières qui attire de
l'année je vais remercier deux personnes
à les accompagner il ya eddy qui a
bouffé tout
façon
il m'attend et voilà
jean-luc le gone
tu sommes pas satisfaits les catcheurs
merci